H
CAROAT
REPRESENTATI GOTHAMLNG ATSS
CONFERENCE TODAY,OW AS
NOW WHERE WE MODERN DAYOCRATSRT
PARTY BECOM
UNRECOGNIZABO SOS THROUGHOUT THS
STATE.ND THIS COULO BUT I REMAII
AM CALLEDARTY T R ME AND MY
REBL HAVE OROLINARTTCH MEANS
PROOF MAJORY  THE STATE
IANPRINCETON FELLOW MAYINING
GREAT YN DO FOR
HER VOTERS WHO JUST VOTED FOR
HER AEWTHS A.  OF
ALL, SHE WAS ENDORSE PAID
FOR HER CAMPAIGN WAS SUPPORTED
AND UNDERWRITTEN BY
S LIKE IL LIST
AND THE N RIGHTS CAMPAI.SHE REPT
IS OVER D
LONGTIMEIS
FEEAITLED TO CHANGER VIEWSKNOW,R
OF SITUATION, BUT SHE LITERALL S
D ON A SET OFNDINGS WITH HERNSTE
SERVICE ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE
AND IN A STATE LIKE NORTHIN THIG
R . TH
RECALL OPTION IN THIS STATE
CNOER
BACKEVHOUGH
MISREPRESENTED HERSELF.
AND I THINKO  AKE JGEE
PULLED THE WOOL OVER
THE EYES ONERKING ABOUT LIKE A
AYS IS NOW ONOLUTIONIT WAS CLELT
THEE. REPREAT COFFIVODUCTIVE
FREEDOM ELECTION LAWS L G B T QF
ITLIE SHE W A
LONG HELD PRPLES.SHOULD VOTE SHE
SEN THESE ISSS REGARDLESS OF HE
WAIN SHE'S
RESENTING HTITUENTS. SOOU
BU, I THINLECTEDCRAT YO MIN
HAVE TO SERVE AS AEMKNOW IT'S AH
MANSIONS AGAARESHE
SWITCHES INAUDIBLE.WITHAT'S NOT.
NTING T PEOPLE.
YOU'RE NSENTING YOURSELF
E VOTED
. YOU COULD ACTLLOWEVERS . YO CD
G THEM THE
SUPERMAJORITY.
FRAUD. IT'GO APPLIED EITHER  A Y
AND GO. NO I DON'T WANT
DIE.
. THAT'S MY FAVORITE
PARTBO
HERE'S WHAT SHES
SHE SWEDPOINT WAS FOR HER AND
ABLU MOMENTS, WHICH
WAS A DEAL BREAKER. A TURNING
POINT FOR ME WAS WHECRITICIZED E
THE PRAYING
EMOJINOST SOCIA
ME PTFND ON THE
BACK OF DFE VEHICLES T
I , I REALLY CASTION THAT WAS H.
ATT TIMEEEPLY
OFFENDEDAT THAT IS
OMHIOT TO BE ABL TO SHOW FLAG TE
LYSKEPTICAL ABOUT THATO CHAN IME
CHRISTIAN OWH
AMERICAN FLAG, WHO ARE DEMOCRATR
MUST BE INCR
THAT MEANS THAT A
THATPUBLICLY
BY EMILY'S. L
THT. A SEY MUST BE INCREDIBLY
SCAREDBOHA MEANS.OUR THTS. SHE'A
B
UNRECO. KN, JOE
MAN IS CONCERNED, AND THE
HERATIC PARTY IST SO MUCH THE LR
'S INCREASINGLY INTOLERANTFENOL
HARDLY.  THAT'S TACALMPLEAT
DONALD J B. I'VE ARGUEATDS G
PERSONALITY CRIS NOT POL.  NO
TRUMPISM APART FROM TNDIZED
WHEREAS STEALINGBERNIEDE SO HOWE
DEMOCRATIC PARTYEEEFT ON ELIMAT,
THE LOWER ENEOSTS ACT THEYWANTMY
WANT MORENERGY. THEY
F THE ABOVE E
STUDENTS OF THIS, TGET THASE THE
MB ON A SECD
REPRESENTED IN TERMS OF THIS. DT
ONE GOTM.NK HAS MISLE HERS?O YOA
CHANGEFF CHANGE T? I TI HAVE BE.
POLITICI WILL BE HELD
ELECTION. THAT'S HOW OU SYSTEMOO
NOT ACKNOWLEDGERE A
DE, THAT YOUR HASMSNOT DEALING
WITH REALITY. DIDN'T SAY I HRU,R
AM PRAYING HANDS
EMOJI'TWISH SHE H SAID AND EXPLD
IF SHE MET OL MEDIA OR
SO PLEASE. IEON'T KNOWH
AL LIKE HAVE TO PUSHLLHIOM CRYIE
ARE WOMEN OFINGAINED DEATH
TH SINGLELDDON'T BELONG HERE. IU
PRESID THAT WAND
T' NOT A BIG
AROUND THE RESEMBLE. IKNOW. I FF
I DON'T FEEL AMERICA OR
WELCOME AROUND THE JLP. SO EVEEM
STIC
ABANDONING RCOMMENT DESCRIBES WN
BEERANTHPOTE Y J
R FOUNDERSM OF
RELIGION ANDT  YOUR
RIGHTSR DIGN
DEPEND ON YOUR RELIGIOUSFIYOUR .
THAT'S THE AMERICAN IDEA'S
OB CAROLINA AND IN THE
MANYRO
IST OMING, IT IS
ESSENTIALLY A TYRANNY OF TH
MINORITY A STATEGISLATURHAT HAS
MAJORITIESBLICAN IN
PLACES WHERE ACTLLY THERE IS
SPLIT AMONG. IT'S N'S IN KANSASS
IT'S ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY WHEREERS,  THE
WAY,NUB VOTERS ARE
SAYING TO REME
AB BS.IG
NUMBER IN AMERICAN
HISTORY. 63%S BOAVE
GETTINSOE NORTH CAROLINA, THIS
FOR MILLIONS DEADLYSEQUCE
VOTERS ABOUT EMOJIS MOCK
BOUT HERNT THEIRTHER THERE TO PT
PATHAT'S
QUICKLY. WAS JUST YEAH,
WHENNCING EVERYONE'S
RIGH